[Musique]
dans ce poulailler nous élevons vingt
mille poules
eric williamson élèves 90 mille poules
pondeuses dans le centre de la suède
ces oiseaux sont tous en liberté en
libre parcours un système qui leur
permet d'aller dehors ou dans des
volières comme celle ci
ce système est optimal pour les oiseaux
eric wilson a déjà élevé des poules dans
des cages enrichi mais il a dû s'en
départir parce que les unes se vendait
tout simplement pas
c'est important pour les suédois que les
poulets comme tous les animaux
d'ailleurs puissent adopter le
comportement le plus naturel possible
comment réagissent-ils en entendant le
mot cage disons que ça ne sonne pas très
bien pourquoi c'est un système désuète
on n'utilise plus a ensuite
les cages conventionnelles ont été
interdites en suède en 1988 après que
les citoyens eurent découvert comment
les poules pondeuses était élevé
rappelle ce spécialiste du bien-être
animal pays
dans les poules sont privés denis elles
vont et viennent dans leur cage dans
tous les sens
quand elles sont privées de litière
certaines d'entre elles des dominantes
tente de reproduire des baies de
poussière en grimpant sur la tête de
leurs congénères et en se frottant
contre leurs plumes
ils ont demandé au gouvernement si on
voulait élever les animaux comme ça
la réponse a été non nos offres adaptées
après l'adoption de la loi l'industrie
suédoise s'est départi des cages
conventionnelles en dix ans la
transition n'a pas été de tout repos
selon cette conseillère de l'association
suédoise les producteurs deux
dames quand les éleveurs ont dû changer
leur façon de faire ça a été difficile
car il n'y avait pas de bons systèmes
d'élevage disponibles la technologie et
les connaissances n'était pas à la
hauteur
ça a été dur mais se sont adaptés ils
sont maintenant très compétent ailleurs
les volières si le futur
elles peuvent sauter deviennent plus
musclé plus en santé les poules sont en
contact avec leurs excréments et c'est
plus risqué pour leur santé c'est vrai
mais à la longue il s'endurcit et
certaines font même plus longtemps
les gens à qui j'ai parlé de l'objet de
votre visite ont été très surpris
nous pensions que le canada était plus
avancé dans la modernisation de ses
systèmes d'élevage
des poules en cage c'est révolu
je pensais que vous aviez abandonné les
cages au canada que vous étiez plus
avancé
dans ses volières eric williamson
n'observe pas de piquage de plumes
excessif un problème courant en amérique
du nord même si poule plus âgés conserve
un beau plumage
nous recevons souvent des visiteurs
d'autres pays et quand on leur dit l'âge
de nos poules ils sont surpris je ne
sais pas si c'est grâce à la nourriture
quand leur donne ou à la façon dont on
les traite
les éleveurs suédois ne sont pas les
seuls à s'être acclimaté au vol hier de
nombreuses études scientifiques ont
récemment conclu que les progrès
importants ont été faits dans les pays
qui ont adopté ce système breveté conclu
la conclusion de cette méta analyse
c'est que lorsque les éleveurs savent
comment s'y prendre avec les systèmes
d'élevage s'engagent les problèmes de
santé sont plus ou moins les maires tir
est propre et
efficace
quand vous laissez vos poules en liberté
il ya plus de risques
l'éleveur doit vraiment savoir comment
s'y prendre pour atténuer les problèmes
photo md
mais quand les éleveurs hawtai qui ce
savoir faire les différences sont
minimes
quoi qu'il en soit en suède ce
changement a été payant pour les
producteurs de forme est prête les
éleveurs sont mieux pays et plus
prospère que lorsque les cages ont été
que c'est ce que les consommateurs
veulent du moins ici
on sait que les consommateurs canadiens
sont comme les suédois à ce sujet là
afin qu'ils croissent yonnais la
question c'est où on seront utiles dans
dix ans que cette chute
optez pour des cages enrichi à ce moment
si elles sont encore bonnes dans dix ans
que ferez vous si les consommateurs
réclament des oeufs de poules en liberté
non cash at a time au canada on est
encore loin de cette réalité au cours
des cinq dernières années le pourcentage
de producteurs 2 de paul en liberté est
passé de 12 à 17% mais l'intérêt des
consommateurs pour le bien-être animal
est grandissant
[Musique]
je pense qu'il faut revenir à des choses
un peu plus saine
quand sur le gâteau c'est de rien
oui on est comme la race on de la chaîne
alimentaire mais justement ça devrait
faire qu'on a un minimum de conscience
qu'on a c'est de bien traiter les
racines grecques sont d'anciens
selon cette agroéconomiste les
prochaines années seront déterminantes
on va aller jusqu'au bout au niveau du
bien être animal parce que j'ai de la
difficulté à vous dire vers roussat
voyait évoluer mais j'ai l'impression
qu'on va en avoir plus haut c'est clair
[Musique]